on Smallville your credit is Paul
wasilowskiwski was it your idea to
professionally change your name or your
agents side note love your bourbon I
love your suit sounds of lambs love it I
love that moment I love you
um
uh my idea I wanted to change it because
my real last name is vashilevsky and the
Americanized pronunciation wasilwski was
driving me crazy so I wanted it to start
with a W and end with an e and I like
literally arbitrarily chose uh Wesley
you know if you were a hockey player you
could keep it I know
by the way what's that one actress Mia
wasikowska or something like that yeah I
know who you're talking about yeah I
know she made it work she should have
changed it